Design engineers work hard to solve problems.
They often share certain characteristics which make them really good at their job.
Frustration can be seen as a bad thing,...
...but for design engineers, it can be the starting point for a really good idea.
Identifying what frustrates you about an existing product can help you make it better.
A successful and well-designed product is something that's easy to use.
James Dyson's frustration with the vacuum bag encouraged him to rethink it...
...and then use a cyclone design instead.
Wrong thinking is allowing yourself to think differently...
...and to not be afraid of trying new and crazy ideas.
Keeping an open mind can lead to a solution that no one has ever thought of before.
It's about thinking your way around a problem...
...and seeing solutions that other people might not.
To answer his brief of creating a small car that could still carry four adults,...
...Alec Issigonis decided to put the engine in the opposite way round.
A perfect design doesn't happen straightaway.
Design is a process.
When something doesn't work first time, it's about sticking with it,...
...making small changes and ultimately, making your design stronger.
You have to learn from things that went wrong,...
...work out why they went wrong,...
...and using that experience, find out how to make them better.
It took Thomas Edison thousands of attempts to invent the light bulb.
And now, it's still used by millions of people every day.
All new designers need to have a bit of fighting spirit...
...and be prepared to keep going in the face of competition.
If you're designing a new product or improving someone else's,...
...you have to convince people that your product is better.
You'll have to explain your product clearly and talk passionately about it.
Design engineers need to be determined.